welcome everybody this is JM Daniel
nitzki in this series I'll be taking a
look at some questions and pieces of
advice that circulate on the internet
and offering my thoughts on them let's
jump
in how to make plans in the middle game
this is a question that every single
chess player is constantly asking me how
do I make plants I think a clarification
is in order here uh I think when when
most people new to chess think of plans
they think that a GM sits down and they
know what you know they know 30 moves
ahead exactly what they're going to play
and they know my Knight's going to go
from H1 to A8 on move 40 but that's not
the reality um I would say the average
length of a plan in chest is something
like two or three moves like just
getting your knight from G1 to E5 is
already a plan so don't think of this as
some sort of large scale thought process
where you're thinking 10 15 moves ahead
that does happen very rarely but a plan
is nothing more than just a maneuver or
a very small OPP Iration so it's not as
grandiose of a term as you might think
it is number four learn from the Old
Masters throughout my career I I feel
that it's been very useful but most of
all very interesting to uh read about
how chess has developed over over the
years and uh to to look at the games the
phrase Old Masters is used pretty
commonly by by chess players and and as
a player or a chess Enthusiast who's
newer to the game you might wonder does
that referred to chess players who lived
in the 1400s uh you know in the in the
time of the Mesozoic Era or you know in
the 1970s because old is a very very
relative term and at least in I don't
think there's a set definition but I
think Old Masters generally refers to
the world champions and the leading
players who came you know something like
1950 and before uh so think Alexander
Aline or Wilhelm Stein it's the first
world champion and even Mikel tall uh
who was world champion in the six s can
be lumped in that category so there's no
set definition it just means the world
champions and and the top players who
came before us and who represented a
different era of Chess
development okay uh to be honest and
I've heard this type of advice that I
would put in the category of just like
General psychology and it's it's good to
have the right mindset um it's it's good
to you know to be confident but at the
same time to not um to not underestimate
your opponent at the same time if you're
a newer player I I would say you need to
focus on what's happening on the board
and you need to try to implement very
concrete pieces of advice like it's much
easier to implement don't double your
pawns or keep your king safe than it is
like Implement tactics over strategy so
yes definitely very good to respect your
opponent but not overestimate him but I
would say focus on implementing more
actionable things on the chest board
rule number three don't push your
kingside pawns this reminds me of an old
the anecdote that my first chess go
shared it's like one of those Soviet
chess Stories the rumor goes that the
world champion T petan was giving a Simo
and he was playing same amateur and he
was the last man standing and petan
barely won and after the game ton asks
the guy and you know you played so well
for someone holding those chest for two
weeks but one immodest question why
didn't you move your Knights the whole
game and the guy said I just haven't
learned how to move them yet so don't
move your kingside Pawns I think that
has to be qualified a little bit the
question is how do you punish mistakes
uh by your opponents man I I really wish
I knew that I'd probably be world
champion this is a pretty general
question and here's how I'm going to
answer it I need you all to start
thinking about mistakes in a different
way because mistakes can happen in a in
a one move situation it's just a one
move blunder a loss of a piece uh your
opponent gives it away and you don't see
it like for example just the dumbest
example I can possibly give you the for
moov checkmate right like that is how
you would you'd punish if they didn't
see it by doing it that's that's it but
there's also the something not as
dramatic and in all your games trust me
you're missing these opportunities both
of you are like whatever level you are
when you're a beginner the focal point
is always just to make sure that you're
not blundering pieces and that you're
taking pieces that your opponent is
offering that should be your complete
Focus until you're you know about 900
1,000 and you've stopped committing you
know regular one move blunders and at
that point you can start focusing on not
committing more subtle types of mistakes
which I think lb is about to talk about
what what what is it what is a mistake
that's not a blunder look like this rule
is that Rooks like to be on open files
and they like being connected what that
means exactly so if I played Rook B8
with black this is what we call a
semiopen file a file is a vertical line
on on the board and in Russian a file is
literally referred to as a line so good
way to remember what a file is so an
open file is when there's absolutely no
pawns on it a semiopen is one pot on
this file on C8 we would call it a
closed file because there's more than
one there's two pawns for files of The
Rook the pieces don't matter so Bishops
Rooks Queens Kings they don't matter
only pawns because pawns are less likely
to change files unless you're capturing
and trading Pawns putting your Rooks on
semi-open fouls is an easy way to
activate them um and here's an example
of how you would connect your Rooks if I
move my queen here they're now defending
each other while this doesn't seem like
it makes a huge difference because you
only moved your queen one square it
makes it easier to take out the other
Rook so now black could maybe bring his
Rook up and double his Rooks now both of
his Rooks are on the game they're in an
semi-open file and they're much stronger
so this is the ideal way to develop your
Rooks of course once you finish your
opening development and doubling your
Rooks means putting both of them on the
same file I wouldn't worry if you're
watching this and you're a newer player
you know this distinction between
semi-open files and open files is less
important than understanding what a
closed file is if you put a rook on a
file that contains one of your pawns
particularly if that pawn is on its
initial Square that's often a bad place
for The Rook just because the Rook is
literally staring at uh one of your
Pawns in a semi-open file you're
generally attacking a targ like an
Andrea's example here the two black
Rooks are aiming at the white Pawn on B2
and putting pressure on it in the case
of occupying an open file you're often
doing that in order to infiltrate your
opponent's territory because there's
nothing on the file uh you're trying to
directly access the second or the first
rank of your opponent both of those
things are very useful great piece of
advice you're often taught this in all
beginner manuals to connect your Rooks
uh to have your Rooks looking at each
other uh this is part of the kind of of
things that you do in chest to make sure
that your pieces are well coordinated
that your king is safe you can consider
it kind of like you know eating your
vegetables or or brushing your teeth at
night it just increases the likelihood
that as the game progresses you're going
to be better equipped for uh the
progression of the game then your
opponent when possible definitely good
practice to connect your
Rooks so I think the first part of that
is the most useful uh especially as a
newer player you want to have an appro
an opening repertoire and you'll hear
that phrase thrown around very often
opening repertoire it's just a set of
openings that you normally play um of
course it's good practice to try
different openings out you can try out
D4 you can try out E4 Now with chessable
uh it's very easy to learn an opening
but definitely as a newer player uh you
want to choose a set of openings that
you play consistently because that
allows you to learn them better uh and
to understand the arising positions
definitely try to settle on a specific
set of openings that you play
consistently but feel free to explore
thousand level but if you're like 1100
trust me there are blunders all over the
place now sometimes those blunders are
one movers and they're crazy obvious but
sometimes the computer will go oh well
this is a big blunder because of a three
move combo which you're incapable of
seeing because you're not at that level
yet so an example that I'll give you for
examp like again here in a Scandinavian
defense okay this is what we have the
queen rotates out this way D4 both
players are developing here it's really
nothing special um black trades that is
an inaccuracy that's not a mistake it's
not good to give away the bishop there
for reasons we've already discussed it's
a very open board okay and now in this
position white finishes development with
Bishop to G5 for some of you watching
the move is obvious here for black for
others not so much some of you might be
thinking okay is this bishop putting me
under any pressure go should I Castle
but I'm going to introduce some
something to you called the checklist
and every move your opponent makes a
move you go what do they want okay then
you go you identify what they want
whether it's scary or not can I create a
check which is the most forcing move in
chess no can I capture anything huh huh
oh attacks the last one would be attack
can I attack something now this is a
great device for newer players and when
you're just learning um I'm not going to
go into like the psychology here but
there's this concept of system one and
system two um it's from it's from a
famous book ritten A couple of years ago
and basically says that when you're a
beginner at something you're using a
very like effortful process you're like
is this move a blunder can I give a
check can I make a mate and this skill
becomes automated it transitions to a
more intuitive way of thinking system
too uh when you gain a lot of practice
so if you're a beginner watching this
and you're like how do GM see this in a
millisecond when I have to go through
this laborious process remember that
this eventually becomes totally
automated like you look at a move and
automatically you're detecting whether
it's a blunder to a very high degree of
accuracy I think the games since um the
capablanca Alin match uh in in
1927 I think ever since then um chess
has been played at a very high level and
uh you can learn a lot from all of the
great Masters yeah that's definitely
true the capablanca Alan series of
matches was fascinating the match that
Magnus is spotlighting here was played
in venos ciris and 1927 um and it
represented a real Clash of styles Alex
Alexander alakin was a very sharp
tactical player cablanca was considered
one of the greatest positional and
endgame players of all time um and you
have to remember that when these matches
were played uh for example capablanca
wrote an opet in the New York Times uh
where he was complaining about how
modern chess has become and how much
information there is to learn and how
chess is dying and you have to remember
that at every era of chess's development
the players living in that era thought
that they were the most modern and the
most developed chess players uh of all
time and truly the the level of Chess
displayed in this match is extremely
high the openings are pretty modern um
it's not like they were uh you know
fighting with sticks and stones so
watching these games it's not like you
will immediately recognize that they
were played 100 years ago you know the
players of that time were actually
really really good thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed my advice
and a huge shout out to botes and Levy
and young Magnus for their amazing
instructional videos If there is a piece
of advice that you would like me to take
a look at and react to please post it in
the comments and I look forward to
seeing you in the next video thank you
so much for
[Music]
watching